the son of a former major league
baseball player is fighting for his life
after he was hit by baseball
Jason Lockhart broke his nose at a
tournament in South Carolina earlier
this month days later the 15 year old
started bleeding heavily doctors
discovered his injuries were much more
severe than they had thought Jason's the
son of a retired Atlanta brave his name
is Keith Lockhart and well ba Baracus
marques is in Atlanta Georgia outside
the hospital where the teenager is due
to undergo more surgery man well good
morning good morning according to his
sister Jason Lockhart was placed on life
support Friday doctors here did that to
keep his movements to a minimum and try
to prevent any further bleeding but his
planned surgery yesterday was postponed
because his body was apparently
responding slower than expected
Jason Lockhart broke his nose in what
seems to have been a freak accident
while running to home plate Lockhart was
struck in the face by a baseball the
catcher was throwing it to the pitcher
to tag him out that was June 17th two
days later during a follow-up doctor's
visit his nose began bleeding
uncontrollably
it's every parent's worst nightmare CBS
News medical contributor dr. David agus
says it's possible Lockhart was bleeding
long before it was detected we see it
sometimes when people are hit and the
bleeding in the head doesn't show up
inside the head till days to a week
later last Tuesday's surgeon stitched a
laceration inside Lockhart's nose when
that failed to stop the bleeding he
underwent several more procedures over
the following days according to his
sister Sydney because even minimal
movements could trigger bleeding doctors
decided to heavily sedate Lockhart and
put him on life support on Sunday
surgeons blocked arteries in his nose
they suspected were the sources of the
bleeding the family was told none of the
blood was coming from Lockhart's brain
when you get trauma to the face you
worried that there be a slow bleed in
the brain but the CT scan should have
showed that Keith Lockhart was a major
league infielder for ten seasons playing
for the Braves from 1997 to 2002 he
retired in 2003 and is now a scout for
the Chicago Cubs following his son's
surgery Sunday Lockhart tweeted we are
all encouraged
about today hashtag stays strong je
Sydney Lockhart reports there has been
no additional bleeding since that
operation and surgeons here are hoping
to confirm that with a procedure this
morning she told CBS this morning her
family has been amazed by the outpouring
of love and urged people to keep praying
for her brother Nora we will keep
praying when well before cos thank you
so much